[Musica]
la settimana scorsa sono auto in
palestra con mia nipote che non lo
vedevo da un po di tempo
una ragazzina di 14 anni e correvamo sul
tapis roulant parlavamo tranquilli
parlavamo dei nostri così parenti cugini
a un certo punto ho notato che era col
cellulare mentre correva costantemente a
scorrere foto e guardava sederi jeans
borsette influencer di turno a una
velocità estrema e mentre guardava tutte
queste cose su instagram
lei mi parlava tranquillissima e allora
un po la mente perversa che all noti
campo matematiche ho iniziato a dire noi
ormai quotidianamente abbiamo
interazione con dati informazioni tutte
bidimensionali abbiamo davanti dei
device degli schermi ed è tutto un xy
quindi abbiamo sempre un rapporto
bidimensionale ormai con tutte le
informazioni che ci arrivano ma anche
alla z la z che è matematicamente
parlando della profondità e
filosoficamente parlando senza neanche
andare troppo in là ed intimità e quindi
c'è qualcosa che manca in questa
relazione tra di vice informazioni i
dati e intimità nella mia testa mentre
lei continuava a parlare ea correre a
guardare il suo cellulare ho iniziato un
po di vagare ma in fondo questo è un po
un viaggio nell'iperspazio perché noi
ormai subiamo quotidianamente o in che
ragione continuamente con uno spazio
bidimensionale mentre un matematico che
guarda allo stesso mondo lo vede come
uno spazio n dimensioni un iper spazio
allora d'alimonte l'idea dicendo che al
ted proviamo tutti assieme a fare un
viaggio nell'iperspazio matematico poi
ragionando detto beh in fondo cosa
potrei raccontare poter raccontare
quello che un matematico dietro veda e
vede 512 dimensione vede tante variabili
poi mi sono annoiato ma in fondo noi
quotidianamente nell'azienda in cui
lavoro facciamo questa attività se
cerchiamo tantissime informazioni tutte
le correlazioni deboli che il nostro
cervello non vede o non percepisce
cerchiamo di estrarle matematicamente
allora ho iniziato a pensare a una
persona
che non solo avesse tra dimensioni ma n
cioè i suoi gusti suoi piaceri le sue
paure come se vedessimo ognuno di fianco
una nuvola di punti che vi rappresenta è
questo un po il modo di vedere da
matematico e poi mi sono reso conto che
io leggo la mia vita o meglio ho avuto
tantissimo influenza nella vita può però
nell'iperspazio cinque anni fa mentre
leggevo moby dick che è un bellissimo
libro tutto il ma il genoa è una scuola
nelle antologie ma pochi lo leggono
arrestate al capitolo in cui elenca come
un dettaglio impressionante di sperma
cetri che non c'entri sessuale l'ispra
marciti voglio dire balene e mentre
l'incauto di queste balene mi sono reso
conto che tutti questi dettagli queste
informazioni che dava che spesso nelle
antologie della scuola nei licei non ha
riportato perché potrebbe sembrare un
eccesso di informazioni quasi un pacco
in realtà erano elementi utili per
entrare nell'ottica di quel viaggio quel
viaggio del capitano da sé la sua belen
ha allora devi matematicamente parlando
caspita è interessante vedere il mondo
in quell'ottica si vede molto di più
sono molte più informazioni e li ho
deciso di cambiare totalmente l'it e di
aprire la mia attività che oggi seguo
con 40 ragazzi per proseguire un po il
nostro viaggio nell'iperspazio cioè
andare a cercare dei dati è sempre
riflettendo su altri dati e altre
informazioni molto come potrei passare
questa informazione alle persone che
incontrerò out ed allora ho pensato alla
musica la musica un'esperienza che tutti
facciamo provate andare a casa da
mettersi le cuffie e ascoltare mozart un
brano di mozart in cuffia con un mp3
poi dopo mettete su un cd
ecco questa è la stessa cosa in quella
mp3 sentirete il brano l'orecchio forse
subito non si accorgerà di cosa manca
poi ascoltando un cd e un altro supporto
che pesa di più a livello di
informazioni vi accorgerete che sono
tantissime sfumature in più che
musicalmente parlando
sono tutte le armoniche che vengono
tagliate andiamo più 3 per renderli più
leggeri ma sono informazioni che mancano
e quindi da qui ha detto beh vorrei
passare un messaggio perché ormai tutti
i filmati separati un intelligenza
artificiale è una cosa infrango chante
sembra tutto un futuro veramente i robot
di intelligenza artificiale che ci guida
intanto l'intelligenza artificiale e
algebra non è niente di assurdo quindi
la libbra non è una cosa che fa paura
in più la si può vedere un po come nei
miei occhi nella mia testa comunque cosa
che spiega il mondo quindi un metodo che
ci serve per comprendere meglio quello
che sta accadendo e non tanto un
qualcosa che ci scalzerà perché tra figo
dire machine learning fa figo dire
intelligenza artificiale
in realtà dietro queste parole che
tengono una certa distanza c'è una
matematica iper affascinante e sensuale
che descrive quello che accade e ci dà
molte più informazioni e quindi vedo
questo strumento di intelligenza
artificiale che dell'algebra come una
cosa che ci potenzierà molto nella
nostra conoscenza per concludere questo
nostro viaggio nell'iperspazio quando
laura mi piace venire a fare questo
intervento vi ho scritto una lettera
ferrovia vicino perché hanno nel geniale
quando ti sarà ambientato
nell'iperspazio matematico ti accorgerai
che è stato riduttivo vedere il mondo
i numeri in un sistema bi dimensionale
xy schiacciati su uno schermo di un
telefono o su un grafico excel del
computer
capirai che un piatto di cibo un sedere
di una ragazza un influencer di turno
hanno un senso se assumono una
profondità una variazione temporale di
angolazione e si è in grado di
richiamare tutti i sensi
serve profondità anche in una relazione
numerica per non appiattire la
conoscenza di noi stessi
camminando nell'iperspazio matematico
potrai incontrare i numeri solitari e
malinconici altri che hanno deciso di
vivere in gruppo e oggi dominano e
governano perché hanno preferito seguire
il correlatore forte una sorta di capo
branco
ci sono poi i numeri un po anarchici
indipendenti e dissidenti che la
collettività matematica definisce in
maniera un po dispregiativa
haier è molto interessante fermasse
chiacchierate con loro sono visionari e
anche un po folli ma spesso fuorvianti e
potrebbero portarci a prendere la strada
sbagliata
ci sono poi i numeri che non amano
uniformarsi alla massa ma dati inclusivi
e sinceri che hanno scelto di vivere per
passione in piccoli agglomerati urbani
dove probabilmente dovrei fermarti se
sei un esploratore o un semplice turista
sono numeri molto sensibili e sarà più
difficile entrare subito in confidenza
con loro tanto che subito ti sembrerà
che il legame che instauri rai con loro
sia di natura più debole una
correlazione debole ma se avrai la
voglia di ascoltarli scoprirà i loro
dati sinceri ed onesti che certamente
daranno un senso molto più profondo tuo
viaggio come è stato detto prima
l'ignoto è molto più vasto del manifesto
ma serve coraggio per uscire dalla
comoda bidimensionalità
[Applauso]
[Musica]